all right well thank you for
attending from napkin to the cloud a
webassembly journey
now first i want to take a quick detour
and explain a little bit of who i am and
why i'm doing this
i created the open source project wasn't
cloud
and i'm also the author of programming
webassembly and rust
so what i want to talk about today is
a journey from
design to production and
i want to comment on how that's
different
when using webassembly as the underlying
technology
to do that first i want to start off
with a real quick
two-minute tour of what webassembly is
and what wasm cloud is
and i'll talk about the application that
we're going to build and that i have
built for this demo
uh what the conceptual design is and
then we'll talk about the actual
building and in this case i'll show some
code
and i'll compare and contrast the
difference between
what i designed and what we ended up
building
and the point there is to see if if
there is a
noticeable gap between the two and then
i'll take
take you through a demo of the
application that we built
and then finally there is a q a period
at the end of the session
so quick tour of webassembly in the
cloud
there's a couple of things that we
typically want in our cloud native
workloads whether we've been using
docker
or we've been just straight up running
processes
there are a number of things that are
fairly common needs that we have
such as security predictability speed
and size and by size i mean
lack of size we want small workloads
and coincidentally what we get from
webassembly is a number of those things
so webassembly is secure
it's predictable it's fast webassembly
modules are small
and i'll show during the demo just how
small that can be
it's portable webassembly can
free us from dependency hell and
it has what i like to refer to as
beneficial limitations which means
there are things that you can't do in
webassembly that you can do freely in
other environments and i think that's
actually a good thing
so if we get all these things from
webassembly and there is this great
overlap between what webassembly gives
us
and what we want in our cloud native
workloads
then maybe we should explore using
webassembly
for cloud native workloads
so web assembly is a stack-based virtual
machine
and without going into too much details
that just refers to
how that virtual machine processes its
instructions
the important point though is that it is
a virtual machine
it's a binary file format that has
a text representation as well
webassembly is cpu agnostic
it's operating system agnostic the
modules are
fast small efficient and
this is probably the the key point here
which is that they're entirely dependent
on the host runtime
so in the case of a web browser the host
runtime
is some kind of javascript engine so in
chrome
it might be v8 and so on but
in the browser your host runtime is
done through javascript when you're
outside the browser
there are a number of different web
assembly host runtimes available to us
we have
wasmtime uh from the vito alliance we
have wasmer
wasn't three which is a popular sea
based library that also has
rust bindings and then we have a higher
level libraries that build on top of
engines like that
um specifically wasn't cloud and
this uh may be a a controversial bullet
point here but i firmly believe
that webassembly is the future of
distributed computing
so wasm cloud ryzen cloud is an open
source project
that i started probably a little over a
year and a half ago
based on these assumptions here which is
if we want all of these things from our
cloud native
workloads and webassembly can give them
to us then
maybe there's an open source project
that can create the
tooling and host runtimes to bridging
that gap and to give us what we need
so wisemancloud is an actor runtime
and for those that are familiar with it
that just means that it
it treats webassembly workloads as
though they're actors as part of the
actor pattern
wasmcloud is it makes it so that your
portable business logic
runs anywhere so that could be at the
edge
in the cloud on iot devices and
also in the browser asm cloud is secure
by default
and in the demo i'll show a little bit
of how that security works
it eliminates boilerplate we want to
strip off
all of the code that we write
day in and day out and service a
boilerplate that really has nothing to
do with our business logic
and our true functional requirements
wisem cloud supports a rapid feedback
loop we have a rebel in one of our
command line tools
uh wasmcloud also provides a
self-healing
self-forming mesh called the lattice
that connects
your host runtimes in
clouds iot devices edges and more it
provides a single flat topology network
that you can use to
manage and observe your active workloads
so let's take a look at the combination
of webassembly and
wasm cloud and we saw earlier that
webassembly
provides security uh most of the
security from webassembly
at the core comes from just the fact
that it contains no
byte code operations for interacting
with the operating system it can't do
things that the host runtime doesn't
allow it to do
it's portable um all the instructions in
webassembly
are cpu and os agnostic webassembly's
fast
it has a small size and then
wisemancloud builds on top of this
by giving us access to loosely coupled
capabilities and those capabilities
might be
web servers database clients message
brokers
those types of things blob stores
seamless distributed compute that runs
anywhere is
a feature that we add through western
cloud you can horizontally scale
your actors and your capability
providers
again i mentioned the actor model
earlier and we also do
contract driven design so when you build
a wisdom cloud actor
you're writing against an abstract
contract
um so you might be writing against the
key value contract or abstraction
or the web server abstraction or
some database client abstraction and not
the actual database itself
which means all of those things can
change at runtime without you having to
rebuild or
redeploy your code
so let's take a look at the sample
application that we
that we built and the idea here was to
to track the and document the journey of
that starts with having an idea and
finishes with
that idea running in production and
[Music]
to take note on how that changes or how
that experience might change
using small composable webassembly
modules
rather than our traditional uh
throw a microservice into a docker image
approach so the application that we're
building is called wisencloudchat
and it's a multi-channel real-time
messaging application so
instead of a simple hello world app this
chat application
has a full backend it records all of the
messages that go through it
and it has multiple inbound and outbound
channels including
uh message broker and uh
for our demo we're going to use telnet
so this is essentially the napkin sketch
or the blueprint for
what we wanted to build for the sample
application and
so you can see that we have some users
coming into the
back end through the telnet channel and
something coming in through the broker
channel
and in the back in the the true back end
we have
functionality lumped together
in categories called presence
which is you know who's online and how
long have they been on line for
messages which is essentially the
message processing and storage rooms
so that's the chat rooms think of those
as channels in slack
and authentication and authorization
and again this is a completely abstract
concept here this is
to represent the idea that we had before
we started
started to implement it
and probably uh
i sort of knew what to expect before i
went down this road of
trying to build out this application
which was that i i've
it in the past my my plans
immediately go work i'm bad as soon as i
try and turn them into an implementation
and whether that's because of tooling or
technology or something else there is
always
a very large gap between my original
idea
and what i'm forced to build in the end
so let's take a look at the journey of
how we generally go about converting our
ideas into something that runs in
production
so we start off with this amazing idea
and we're inspired and that inspiration
gives us just enough energy
to get over and around that next curve
and so we have this idea that we then
convert into a design
and the design is that abstract design
that has very little to do with the
actual implementation
and it's just a rough sketch of what it
is we're trying to build
we then do some early experimentation on
this idea
and then that early experimentation
invariably results in us having to throw
away everything that we've done
including some of our original uh ideas
and redo what we were building and
that's maybe because we learned some
valuable lessons or we got some
technical things incorrect but this
iteration of experimentation and
redesign is
pretty common including another
round of refactoring and redesign
and during that process we might
actually get something out into
production
and deployed but it's
certainly uh in in many cases nothing
like what we wanted to
to build back when we had our amazing
idea and this of course leads to despair
and so what i'm hoping is that through
the combination
of webassembly and other cloud tooling
we might be able to change this journey
for the better
so we start off again with our amazing
idea
and then we get to an initial design our
napkin drawing which
i drew on a slide earlier and then again
we go to early experimentation and i
think this is where the paths diverge
the results of the early experimentation
is going to be different this time and
that's where we're able to
quickly and easily deploy and test our
experiments
in different environments including
production and production simulated
environments
and then the iterative process after
these successfully deployed experiments
is now instead of complete refactors and
redesigns
we're just able to tweak things change
the knobs on our scaling
and deployments and the shape of our
final production environment to deal
with
scale and expected volume and load
and we haven't had to throw away any of
our initial conceptions this way
and this hopefully leads to joy
so back on the original journey path
of microservices when we build our
services with hard service boundaries
uh i think work if you've built any
microservices this pattern should look
pretty familiar
each one of these represents one of the
potential
units of deployment that we might want
to build and if we're building this
as regular microservices a small
fraction of each one of these services
on the screen is our business logic
but then we now have all of these
embedded dependencies
each one of these has an rpc client in
it some of them have
message broker clients there's a telnet
server and one of them
there are database clients and in others
there's caches
all of these non-functional requirements
and
as alluded to earlier the problem with
these is that these are now
dependencies that we own and they are
tightly coupled
dependencies and even if we've managed
to compile these we're still in a form
of dependency hell because
if we want to change how we get our
telnet services
from one approach to another
we have to refactor and rebuild and
redeploy
if we want to change one of our database
clients from
redis to cassandra we have to refactor
and rebuild and redeploy
and that entire cycle happens
a lot more often than we expect and
so these hard service boundaries are
very much like
uh containment walls and not in a good
way
and so hopefully we can do better and so
with webassembly and using wisem cloud
actors
and a bunch of beneficial open source
runtimes
we can get flexible service boundaries
so
one deployment option here would be to
have a single runtime process that has
all of our actors in it
so we can choose on our laptop
during early development to have a
monolith
because it's the most convenient and
it's the easiest to work with for that
time
and then as we experiment and we start
needing different shapes to handle
different loads we can split that we
could split it into
two runtime hosts and now we have our
actors
spread in different ways across the
different hosts and we can pick and
choose which ones go where
we're not locked into any binding
between an actor and a host at compile
time
and finally we could also choose the the
super micro
micro service where one of our hosts is
hosting one actor
and we could choose that for a number of
reasons
but the important point is that this
choice
is now at least in the world of
webassembly
a runtime an operational choice and not
a
an architectural design choice that is
baked into
the overall implementation of the system
so let's take a look at how we built it
and i'm gonna go through some rust
fairly quickly but
the main thing that i want to show that
i want you to keep in mind as i go
through this code
is not what the code looks like but
what's missing from the code
and so in this one the first thing that
an actor does is it righteous areas
the message handlers actors are reactive
and they they receive messages and they
emit a reply
to those messages and so in this case
one of these actors is is simply
registering a handler
to process messages
and again let's take a look at the code
more with an
eye towards what's missing in this
snippet we can see
that it's publishing a message to
uh the backend and this this code is
actually
from the message broker channel which
acts as a
proxy between the outside message broker
and the
the back end inside our chat system
which is
far more complicated than a hello world
sample but what's missing
is actual communication with a tightly
coupled broker
that publish function just takes the
topic
a reply topic and the payload to publish
the choice of which broker is doing the
publishing
how that broker does the publishing and
what configuration we use
in order to enable that publisher that
broker to publish
that's all done at runtime we could
completely swap out
rabbitmq for kafka for gnats without
having to recompile this actor
or even redeploy we could swap those at
runtime
similar scenario here with data services
so in this one we
are adding a room to the chat back end
and in order to do that we need to
communicate with a database
and in this case we're communicating
with a key value store
but the again what's missing from here
is that the key value store
isn't actually defined here we're
referring to the key value abstraction
but we're not talking explicitly to
redis
or to cassandra or memcached or etcd
we're simply saying set this key to this
value and add this value
to a a set with this key
and again the binding of the provider
is done at runtime
all right so now i'm going to take
through a quick demo
of the chat application that we built
and i'll show
all of this code in action and more
importantly
i'll show this the incredibly small
size of the of our unit of distribution
and our unit of compute and how flexible
it is
and the options that we have without
needing to recompile anything
and again before i get into the demo i
just want to have this slide up here
real quick
as a brief reminder of the architecture
that we're building
everything with a gear and in one case a
padlock
is an actor written in wasmcloud
for the system and i'll go through that
in a second
all right so let's get started with the
demo i've got
a couple of terminal windows open here
because uh in general
my demos are pretty devoid of graphics
i'm going to be going through some
console stuff
and we'll be using the telnet channel
on the chat example so the first thing i
want to go through
is looking at some of the actors uh you
saw some of the source code for the
actors
in the slide deck that i
went through earlier and i just want to
show you uh what that what that sort of
looks like in the shell here
so what i want to look at
is first how small these things are
so
[Music]
if i take a look at
the signed uh version of
our actor which is just a wasm file
you'll see that it's actually
only 702 k and when you think about
the unit of deployment for most
microservices
even if we're using a language that's
known for
fairly small self-contained binaries
nothing produces binaries as small as
700k
and we're able to embed them with a
cryptographic signature
that tells the runtime what these
modules are allowed to do
so if i inspect the claims
on this module you'll see
that uh what i've got here is the name
of the actor which is called
a telnet channel and the actor has an
account
a module expires can be used and so on
and if you're
paying close attention and you've seen
json web token before you'll recognize
that these are
similar fields where we have an issuer a
subject
and then some other fields for how that
certificate or how that
token can be used but more importantly
this telnet channel
is capable of using the key value store
messaging broker logging extras for
random number generation and the telnet
capability
and uh it's it's worth pointing out
that nowhere in that list of
capabilities is there
a specific mention of
a vendor project so we don't mention
redis we say that you
can use the a key value store and so on
so that was that's the telnet channel
and
we also have in the actors list
we have authorization a broker channel
so anything that is using let's say
gnats can use naps as a gateway into the
chat system
we have the messages actor a presence
actor for determining who's online
rooms and then again the telnet channel
so
what i'd like to do next is start up a
wisdom cloud host
and i want to start all of the important
actors
i want to start all of the capability
providers
and then i want to configure those and
we do that through
a manifest file and first looking at
this manifest file
may seem a little bit overwhelming a
moment using yaml here
for an example you can also use json
there's no no requirement there so
the first thing we have on lines five
through seven
is a list of actors that we want to
start up and it wasn't cloud host
and then on lines 9 11 13
15 and 17 you'll see we're actually
using a thing called an image ref for a
capability
and what that means is we're actually
able to load a capability provider
from an oci uh
registry that means that we can store
them the same way
you store document niches and we can
retrieve them the same way you
you retrieve docker images and so we
have a number of our
first party capability providers sitting
in our wasm cloud
oci registry in azure and then
starting on line 18 we have links and
link
definitions uh essentially consists
of the actor the provider that we're
linking to
and then in the name of the link and
then
a set of parameters so we think
environment
variables and so if you see here we've
got the broker channel
actor is being linked to
the uh front-end version of
the broker the wasm cloud messaging and
so
by using these two different link names
we can actually have
two different instances of the same
capability provider
but with different configuration
parameters and so in this case
we have a mats broker configured
with a front-end connection string and
one configured with the back-end
connection string
so as we go through here you'll see
there's telnet we configure the telnet
actor by allowing it by configuring it
with
logging extras access to the telnet
provider
and access to a key value store and
[Music]
you'll see that that key value store is
configured to
communicate with redis so if i start
wasmcloud with this manifest file
you'll see a whole bunch of
log spam that should look fairly
familiar to
anybody who has spent time looking at
microservices
standard outlooks in kubernetes or any
other cloud environment
most of this is informational not really
worth going into too much detail
but you can see how we have a
discrete log of all of the actors all of
the providers that are running
if an actor stops and starts we'll see
that here
if one if a capability provider stops
and starts we'll see that there as well
so the first thing we now have is we
we know that we have a telnet provider
running
and because we configured it we know
it's running on port 8500
and we got a fancy ascii art
welcome message so we'll log in here i
shall
those are the list of the commands that
we support and i mentioned earlier
the back-end system deals with things
like storing and retrieving messages
as a stream uh creating and deleting
rooms joining rooms
and all of that sort of thing and then
the channels
are responsible for the actual
communication so right now i'm using the
telnet channel
and i typed a message there and since
there was no one listening if there's no
one listening to
a real-time chat message in the forest
uh did it actually happen and
if we go into our redis cli we'll see
that
it indeed did still happen so i'll take
a look
at the stream for the general room
and don't worry if the rate of syntax
isn't familiar it's not all that
important right now
but you can see what's what's what
happened here is
i have a stream of messages that has
been going
through the different rooms in my in my
chat back in and this most recent one
uh we have a each message has a unique
id the text was
hello from kubecon we can see the origin
user
is a wasn't cloud chat url
there's a timestamp on it and the origin
channel is the telnet broker
now assuming that we have other channels
running we might have
as an origin channel you might see the
the nats broker or you might see an irc
broker or even a slack broker or a slack
channel
depending on the integrations that we
support
it's designed to support any number of
integrations written
using wisem cloud actors so but in any
case
the the moral of this story isn't
that i've been able to build a
chat application the moral of the story
is
that we've been able to build the chat
application by composing
tiny units of compute and distribution
that literally consume no more than one
meg each
that are cryptographically signed that
have a verifiable
secure prominence that can be deployed
anywhere
and can connect to capabilities that are
also deployed anywhere
i can choose to run this entire thing
as a monolith which is what i'm doing in
this one terminal window
or i could choose to run it as any
number of processes as i want i could
run
30 copies of one actor and 12 copies of
the capability provider that it speaks
to
and the wasn't quad runtime takes care
of
distributing the function columns
between
those and makes it all seamless for you
so the the end result
of the experiment that we did to build
this chat application
was that thinking about
the problem that we were trying to solve
was uh almost directly in line with how
we solved it
when we went with building actors
and connecting them to capabilities
versus
other avenues that might have been
higher friction had we decided to go
with the traditional microservices route
so if i could ask one thing it would
just be to
take a look at the tutorials and kick
the tires
and see if
you know your next microservice project
might be something that you might want
to
make as your first
webassembly in the cloud project thanks